I researched one piece for over 200
hours and found 12 theories that would
explain everything for example there is
this wild theory about laughtail devil
fruits and Shanks that not many people
talk about did you ever notice that two
of the people on Roger's ship got really
sick when they were approaching
laughtail you probably did and it's easy
to dismiss this as a coincidence but I
don't think it was you see the only two
people that got sick and didn't make it
to laughtail were buggy and Toki and
they were the only two confirmed people
with devil fruit powers on the ship so
is it possible that devil fruit users
get sick as soon as they get close to
laughtail well I think this Theory
actually makes sense and there is one
more important thing that is hinting
towards it in chapter 1054 Shanks tells
Ben that it's finally time they go and
claim one piece now the interesting
thing about red hair Pirates is that
none of them are confirmed to devil
fruit users Shanks may already know that
devil fruit users can't go to laughtail
and therefore forbade anyone in his crew
to eat one this would also make
red-haired Pirates the only pirate crew
able to get the one piece at the end of
each Theory I'll also speculate how
probable it is to be true and for this
one I'll give the score of 6 out of 10.
this is only the first out of 12
theories I am covering today and the
last one is the most insane Theory I've
ever heard so you all know about the
five elders but do you know how old they
are what if I tell you that they may
just be immortal okay let me explain not
much is known about the Goro say but one
main thing supporting this theory is
that they looked exactly the same 20
years ago in O'Hara flashback the one
way they could achieve this is through
oppa opanomi and its ability to Grant
immortality other than that there is not
much backing this Theory and knowing
that looks in the anime can sometimes be
deceiving I don't think this theory has
high probability of being true okay so
what exactly is one piece well there is
this one theory that would actually make
a lot of sense so in my opinion the one
piece is some kind of object which was
confirmed by Oda himself by the way that
would allow Luffy to destroy the red
line all right but why would the straw
hats want to do this well this actually
ties in perfectly with their original
dreams Luffy wants to be the king of
pirates and the freest person in the
world if the red line is destroyed he'd
be able to travel wherever he wants and
would bring all people closer together
Nami wants to make a map of the entire
world which would definitely be much
easier if this big lion weren't
separating it in half Sanji wants to
find the all-blue all four C's together
which is exactly what would happen if
Redline is destroyed and finally Brooke
wants to fulfill his promise and reunite
with laboon and since the crew is now in
the new world the Boon is right behind
the red line the last thing supporting
this is Madame Shirley's prediction that
Luffy will destroy the Fishman Island
which would also come true since it's
located right under the red line I have
to give this Theory 8 out of 10 points
since in my opinion it has a good chance
of actually happening Marshall D teach
or Blackbeard is one of the weirdest
characters in the entire story besides
his appearance an enormous love for
cherry pies there is something else
really weird about him I believe that
Blackbeard has multiple personalities
three to be exact there are a few
crucial moments that prove this when he
first met Luffy while eating pies in the
restaurant he seems really childish
competing with Luffy who can order more
food and generally had a comedic Vibe
however only a few moments later when he
met Luffy again outside of the
restaurant he seemed much more calm and
mature he gave Luffy a speech about
dreams and wished him luck in finding
the sky island after this conversation
Luffy and Zoro would both comment that
Blackbeard is not he but they another
huge fact supporting this theory is that
teach is the only character who can
wield the powers of two devil fruits
without dying a few additional details
are that Blackbeard's flag has three
heads he has three pistols around his
belt and his beard is split into three
parts alright the next theory states
that you will subscribe to this channel
in the next five seconds and it has a 10
out of 10 probability of happening 54321
okay thanks let's move on are you ready
for an insane theory about God Valley
and Shanks of course you are here it is
you probably know that God Valley
incident happened 38 eight years ago at
first I thought that there is nothing
unusual with this but then I Googled
shank's age and you won't believe what I
found Shanks is exactly 39 years old
which means he was a baby during the god
Valley incident now we know that Shanks
was a member of Rogers Pirates even as a
young child but how exactly did he join
the crew here is when this Theory comes
in I think Shanks is the son of rocks
think about it after they defeated rocks
either GARP or Roger probably went to
his ship to make sure that there is no
one left when they searched the ship
instead of fighting Pirates they found a
one-year-old baby Shanks since it was a
baby of a pirate it's likely that it
wouldn't be treated very nicely by the
world government therefore GARP
entrusted baby to Roger another very
interesting fact that's confirming this
theory is that when Roger held
mamonosuki and hayori he said it's been
a while since I last held a baby hinting
that there was a baby on the ship a long
time ago alright let's talk a bit about
the first warlord Luffy came across sir
crocodile in episode 443 during the
impel down Arc it was revealed that
ivankov has some history with crocodile
their history was never dwelled upon but
crocodile got really uncomfortable while
talking with him based on this and the
fact that ivankov was shown to be able
to change a person's gender the theory
of crocodile originally being a woman
becomes a strong possibility there are a
few great details backing this Theory
the first one is that ivankov
intentionally called crocodile croco-boy
which may just subtly imply that wasn't
always a boy another great detail is
that during Roger's execution crocodile
is the only character whose face wasn't
shown I actually went back to check this
and it's true though Flamingo buggy
mihawk and Gekko Moria all have their
faces shown the only face that we don't
see is crocodiles so why does Sanji have
fire-based powers in the show it was
explained that he simply spins at high
speeds and heats up his legs due to
friction but what if there's more to it
than that well my theory is that Sanji
is actually genetically modified to be a
lunarian by his father I know what
you're thinking how would that be
possible I also didn't believe it at
first but when I did some research I
found out two very important things that
support this Theory you see sanji's
Father Judge was working with Dr
vegapunk and Queen on some kind of off
the legal weapon development and there
he learned about lineage factor which is
basically a way to create life itself he
later used this to modify his children
while Sora was still pregnant so what if
he used some of the lunarian DNA on
Sanji during this time well we know in
the past the the world government
captured King and experimented on him
due to his lunarian powers so it
wouldn't be a stretch to say that judge
somehow obtained some of King's DNA that
the world government had and used it on
Sanji I already hear you saying how
sanji's modifications were unsuccessful
because he didn't lose his emotions and
didn't get any special abilities but
that doesn't have to mean anything as we
saw in raju's case a person can still
retain emotions even after these
modifications maybe sanji's Powers just
took longer to manifest than usual five
more theories are left and this next one
about Monkey D Dragon actually has a 9
out of 10 probability of happening even
after 1 000 episodes Oda still didn't
fully reveal dragon's exact powers and
abilities but don't worry there are a
few scenes in the anime that tell us
exactly what they are ever since his
first appearance in log Town Dragon was
seemingly always accompanied by strong
gusts of wind this by itself doesn't
prove much but when you remember that
Luffy was saved from being executed by
random lightning from the sky and that
they managed to leave loketown safely
because strong winds push them away but
becomes much more clear that dragon has
weather-based abilities also I thought I
remembered the scene where Dragon is
actually seen flying using wind so I
went back to check and I was right in
episode 737 you can actually see Dragon
levitating while carrying Sabo onto his
ship alright let's talk about one of the
most mysterious characters in the entire
show and the huge secret he may be
hiding of course we are talking about
Shanks and the theory that he is
actually a Celestial Dragon there are
actually two big hints why this may be
true firstly in chapter 580 when Shanks
arrived at Marine Ford he managed to
convince zengoku to stop the war and
give him the bodies of Whitebeard and
Ace in order to prepare a proper burial
it's already really weird wise and Goku
would listen to a dangerous pirate-like
Shanks but what's even more interesting
are the exact words he set only because
it's you red-haired I'll allow it it's
really out of character for sengoku to
do something like this no matter how
powerful Shanks may be the second big
hint happened in chapter 907 when Shanks
entered Mariola in order to talk with
five Elders it's absolutely Unthinkable
that any pirate would ever be allowed to
enter that place especially the one of
the most wanted criminals in the world
one of the elders even said almost
identical world's SN Goku only because
it's you we made time to talk while we
are talking about Shanks there is one
more really interesting theory about him
you all know that Shanks was the one who
initially motivated Luffy to become a
pirate he even sacrificed his arm and
said that he bet it on the new age well
since he was the reason why Luffy went
to the Sea don't you think it would be
fitting if he was also his last obstacle
and won in the possession of the last
Road poneglyph I think that it's highly
possible that right before Roger
disbanded his pirate crew he told Shanks
to hide the last pong glyph and asked
him to guard it so it would not fall
into the wrong hands some years later
after Shanks heard Luffy say the same
words Roger once said Shanks finally
found the person he was looking for and
he bet his arm that Luffy will become a
pirate worthy of One Piece before we
cover the wildest theory on this list
let's first cover this very interesting
theory about fujitora and akanu the two
didn't have a lot of conversations with
each other throughout the show but there
was one conversation in chapter 712 that
revealed one very interesting fact
during this conversation fujitora calls
Akainu sakasan which is informal and not
really expected since Akainu holds the
highest rank of Fleet Admiral because of
this a lot of people myself included
think that this is probably suggesting
that the two are related to each other
most likely being Brothers I was doing
research for this video I stumbled upon
a one-piece Data Book and in there it
was written that the two Admirals seem
to know each other pretty well which
further proves this Theory and the final
thing is that after the incident in just
Rosa the only punishment Akainu gave
fujitora was not to return to any Marine
base until he captured Luffy and law I'm
pretty sure that if any other Admiral
embarrassed the world government like
that there would be a much stricter
punishment alright so did you ever
notice the left eye symbolism throughout
the entire show take the these manga
volumes for example they all feature a
character with a closed left eye also a
lot of characters in the show have some
kind of marking on their left eyes this
includes Luffy GARP Dragon sorrow Shanks
Sabo and kid a lot of people say that
all of this probably means nothing but I
don't think that's true me and a bunch
of other fans actually think that this
solves one of the biggest mysteries in
the entire one piece okay hear me out do
you remember the sky Pia and Jaya arcs
where it was revealed that both Islands
were one island in the past well if you
look closely you'll notice that Jaya has
a huge hole where the left eye of the
skull is supposed to be due to
everything we previously mentioned this
also can't be a coincidence and a lot of
fans believe that jaya's missing left
eye is actually laughtail this would
also make sense considering that Roger's
treasure is called one piece and
laughtail may exactly be one piece Jaya
is missing if you want to learn more
about this Theory Ohara made a great
video on it a while back so make sure to
check out his video for a detailed
explanation